all right I want to give the Pope some
props this week because i love you saw
this but the Pope Pope Francis has been
a pretty cool Pope as far as Pope's go
Anna Pope's me pretty cool but his guys
a cool Pope uh you know first up he's
down with the gays basically people he's
not built for lead our gay marriage it
settled on everybody he has actually
said some nice things about gays he
doesn't want the church to focus about
gays that's pretty good and guess what
rome wasn't built in a day he knows he
lives in rome and it's changing its
changing it's happening you want
religion to kind of come around you want
old thoughts to come around well they
don't just happen overnight the Pope is
kind of coming around on gays but even
better than the gay thing this week he
said that he basically believes in
evolution and the Big Bang Theory now
this is the Bing that gets everybody
freaking out about religion right
because they think I repeat the
religious people everyone says they
believe it's a literal translation and
God seven days and he created this and
that many rested and you wherever he
went to Florida whatever it was but the
Pope is now coming and saying you can
believe in this book this thing that I
got here that everyone's always talking
about and you can believe in what
science has proven now this is pretty
good this is a huge step and I think you
got to give props where they are where
they are due this guy is actually trying
to change this thing I'm not a
particularly religious person I'm not
even Catholic but I can acknowledge when
good things are happening and that's
what this guy is kind of trying to do
and this is what it's all about so you
can't you gotta let go of the old
hatreds right so you want people on one
side want the Pope to let go of the gay
stuff let's say you're that kind of
thing or misogyny in the church or
whatever it is they want them to let go
of that well then at the same time those
people as they see the church change and
as this guy this Pope guy who's pretty
influential right Sophia Petrillo loved
him as he changes and as the doctrine
changes well then you gotta acknowledge
that so that they can see oh there's a
reason to say and do the right thing so
I am down with the new pope and I don't
know that he's coming to me for advice
but I think he follows me on twitter
I'll let somebody will check on that I'm
pretty sure he follows me on Twitter so
Pope pontiff I'm down with what you're
doing great on the gay thing fantastic
on the evolution thing
you know the hat and the whole thing
it's all it's all good so good work Pope
you've got a fan over here